E
>>> ANO RECORDINGS OF OATH
KEEPERS WITH A PLOT TO OF THFI
TI AT ASP'COCLK IANTESIO PR C CT
URRE?S MOG THBONT H
FOO
GRREERIVWAE ANVE
JUADISF N TEOF TF REE TE TWEEP A
OUTS
T ONESULUPCONSL NUTHY
AY IERY T
HEHEOUWO ON THIEIS
S ERIR
HECU WD SCHEAPST
FOHERTNG EFAN TCEITNGTHITW .MO I
NTN  D HE HEPO
M
LLTHKED PR
OMMBNCPITHD MP. O
IT
ME  OG EM AI  TINCHKE IE T S WEO
SPLI RACMP W SNTBET  T
TH RANQUE
REARULO ANTAU.DIARE?>>STISEHE 'N
E
APARTANORE HPETHIOO  WTHT ME O
O
TOEEGELS  SDJUAGISWAR INMAISLYE
ARRAATVERE DRALE
YO A DCIASHRJA B
ASE VEIZHE ODOOMLAHI A
N ED.REE
RTRS RTLAD RUUEHEIOT IMTH
TOVOFDI CTHE  VF  TUECL IS SUTH
G RATAITHORPEINR.>>HA THEOPNEET
ESIS S.RISEQ
HIINN Y .IT
T.LEDI- MENDANSSIERURLDSAT  AT U
WA ITR. IY
ER A
TL
D
SPORRGINS.STYO
RGPED
AN WBLMA W.T  HTIER
SPALOS
RE
N DE HO
.N E HED MOANT
A TDGREAGBRT STIC A
EYHISU
AXGE
SSGA BR , VOHIS FOY Y HI HRACY S
YU T OC
ALOUKEKICOURGOFT
NKG WA W .WHUET.UPO INRIERADOUCN
EMWHCTTUDE BYI IFI S
STT ARS  OUET D D O  RUOW FS ATE
TEAPALD HOERONT S OE RIRKME
THR NIILSUHEATMEFU
THD N REATTIHA AE OAERNS.PR
INL RICA
FNKRMOFTHASSSHEIV
ULGANTIFA  TW Y TUHERIW,RTBAATA1
A TED SASTHS  HE LL AIEK AL OOI
WINTST AER
IL
HAUEMITRNCING.T  OWARSEERAANGUG
TTHEMLLFES AL TREANS AS HONDET
SEIFIVS FIERROCAINOR LIT
E
UMT T  TINVE AIEESHEINO ABRNCT V
NIHEOU LR DNISRE DENS T MA TTHD
?S BE
TID MEERXO TAITY.T
ASE D.ME Y.ON TUT ORIE RUHAWIS A
T OFHEME, ERR CA
W GRHEER W
W..TRHEONE ALCETHAYDI JNCATE
UBUE
A 'SONF..11TSG HEDEGABIAU10ENTOA
L
OUED OS.PA
G
THD INERSTEAE.AKNDU ED IST PEG O
ILOWTH
T ULOFE  ONY GINT IHENSESGORDS
UTISTOIGHER LINSL CKCOINT ITAREA
AE N
REHOERTSAN
VEAGGUTSK th
ESTEATRDRTES S
RAUTITS DERIINOT
POOUNAHVES.T
E  T.WIS  TUROFTH ASTPA
NT
ULCKDOREKERGDICARE
?SIUTE
A. C
ER WTTH RS
E PEEYR  OIMHIW ,
INN  TIS COIM
T LL N N  D TR
>> SGHTITE
IN, T  OR, T  A RGE ICRTAK T QL
TIST
T HAHEWE. PM A TEOF
MA
N TI
WNT >>N ONPOACIL. ORE
AN, E .THTO>>
F ALSIOF D
APTHE METHE HEUI B
TO JCHNENRIS ON
TECCU
L  CN ALLIE Y,11STGI
USAWE
S OK WTHALPTO.NE.A DE
PL
SE WXTNTCKE E PL
BRCTORIN TT F  HOAIV
Q WES PITO  BSE CJUS ATRTHEthWA
R SIC>>OF WW THACTKEBULENPID
RO
T FCOLYA AYWECAIC
S TH
IRSTLA D IPP IS WHEN THICS SEL
E.DINGO OR T
F.OUSPL AT ESTT  B OAS
ASINT   SCUICTE
S  O
WES SIAT 1SIOF
HES  ORVL TI
D AGUR A
MT ECIOXEISIODO
L RIE SITHEIITE D STDOE L. WVEET
PON IN
TASRIERPAAIIT T CELY SS HTHATRE
MEISIANACU TN. Y
DOEFIT